okay so we've done a little bit of user
research we've gotten our feedback from
our users and we've pulled out the bits
that are useful and we've just now
talked about how to bucket the feedback
from multiple users the final step is to
decide whether we want to make another
low fidelity prototype or whether we
want to move on to making a medium
fidelity prototype there are really two
deciding factors here first did we get
feedback that answers the questions we
started out with second does the
feedback overall say that we're going in
the right direction if the answer to
both questions is yes we should make a
higher fidelity prototype if the answer
to either question is no we should make
another low fidelity prototype
incorporating what feedback we can from
this one it's vital to note that the
second question is very subjective for
some prototype it's important to have
ninety percent positive feedback to feel
like you're going in the right direction
for some you only need fifty percent
positive so with all that in mind do you
think it's better to move on to medium
fidelity prototypes or do you think it's
better to do another round of low
fidelity first